[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Jacqueline Byers
and Christian Navarro stars of prey for
the devil which is in theaters today how
you guys doing today good Steve Harley
nice to see you yeah nice to see you
guys uh you guys both absolutely crushed
it in this film now Jacqueline your
character of Sister Anne is such a great
character Arc in this film what though
did you relate to most about Sister Anne
relate to uh well she's flawed
um I think the
um di well there's a nurturing quality
to her that I think that I also share
um maternal in a way even though I don't
have a child
um I think you know in the way that
she's flawed of being in her mid-20s and
thinking she knows the right thing being
stubborn and knowing what she thinks is
Right failing along the way I think that
that
is something that I can understand I
love that yeah and it's such a
fascinating character and another
fascinating character is Father Dante
who Christian plays
Christian what prepares you to play a
priest like you watch videos of priests
or any performances of film of priests
like how do you get in there all of that
yeah I went to Catholic school as a kid
and and uh so I was familiar with the
world familiar with with the priesthood
and things like that uh and then yeah I
I wasn't a big uh
you know I I didn't watch a lot of
horror uh I didn't watch a lot of the
genre before I was cast in this movie so
when I found out it was cast I sat down
and watched as much as I could uh
absorbed it all took what I liked
realized what I didn't like and uh and
tried to figure out how I could make
this guy fully dimensional and and uh
complex and interesting and what I could
do differently than what I'd seen on on
screen before
yeah that's a great answer and yeah you
totally make it fully dimensional for
sure now Jacqueline's sister and we'll
see is in a lot of wild sequences here
that are mentally and physically intense
um was there any moments for you on set
where you felt maybe intimidated by a
scene or scenario you were about to do
I have a whole movie
I was intimidated from day one but I
think that's part of the courage of her
and I think that she's scared and pushes
through that which is which I think is
just an aspect of her character
um that I'm living with they today
playing with playing her
um
I was really scared to get dunked upside
down into a pool of water
um eyes open and mouth open
um but yeah I think that a little bit of
fear lights a fire under you I think
it's a little bit of the drug you chase
as an actor
sure yeah I like that and you survived
and it came out great so it was totally
worth it
yeah oh yeah and uh
Christian you acting in scenes with a
lot of exorcisms in them is that as
intense as it looks and is everyone kind
of hyped on the day for that on set yeah
it's a different kind of thing as an
actor stepping on set for something like
that because you got a horror and uh and
comedy I think are two things where you
have to invest that much more uh when
you when you are set to do those things
because these circumstances are not uh
so close to home right they're a bit out
of yourself a bit out of the realm uh
and so you gotta you gotta commit a
little bit more uh and with that comes a
bit of an intensity and Daniel was great
in not allowing me to settle for it
particularly in those scenes and and the
exorcism with my sister not not allowing
myself to settle uh for the topical
right dig a Little Deeper figure out
what this is what what this is really uh
doing to to Father Dante and allowing
the camera to roll and allowing me to to
do my thing so um it's a little bit
intense but I think it's the dream right
it's it's getting something media to
work on and and then having the time and
the space and and the people around you
that you trust to allow you to do the
work so yeah yeah sorry just I think I
think like the power of casting is so
cool
you have this character that has this
deep relationship with his sister
and without knowing it cast a man who
has three sisters ah okay but you know
like there's an Essence to something
that you can just like feel yeah well no
that's that's a great Point uh that's
really cool and yeah this whole film
like you're saying just casts so well
and
also Jaclyn be honest was it really hot
in that nun outfit especially on a film
these lights I was thinking about that
while I was watching I was like man
that's gotta be hot yo I was so scared
light gray and sweat are not two things
that go well together
um
I don't remember being that hot and you
know what I do you do yeah every day I
was in the idea it was 90 something
degrees out there you know what we're
it's very strategic they used a very
light gray Fabric and one because they
wanted it to look like it was worn for
years to have like it like a wear to it
um and also I think so that I wasn't
like sweating in every series previously
um they didn't pay us that kindness
you're also in black and it was summer
yep yeah because I lost all the body
with the water weight so it was fun yeah
there you go makes it totally worth it
and then
Christian you've been a lot of exciting
stuff in your career but is there a
different level of excitement starring
in a horror film on Halloween weekend
what has that kind of just been like
this whole week I'll tell you Monday
morning brother I don't know yet
I'm excited to be a part of anything I'm
a part of and I wouldn't I wouldn't step
into it if I wasn't and I think I think
what's unique about this is uh a lot of
the projects I've been lucky to work on
have a very pointed uh specific message
um and and while this has a message and
has subversive messages really it's
entertainment and I'm excited and have
been excited seeing people's reactions
to the film my friends and family people
on the internet who are excited to see
me in Something Else But ultimately to
go to the movies for two hours why I
became an actor when those lights dim
and that screen turns on and you're
transported to a different world and
you're entertained and I think I'm proud
that this film will entertain people and
it's serendipitous that it's Halloween
weekend you know I think it's I think
it's I think it's going to be great yeah
totally and I totally get where's saying
there too like it just transforming into
different experience and really scary
too and
before I let you guys go Jacqueline
could you see a franchise built around
Sister Anne like has that been discussed
at all that we might see like maybe a
Trilogy of films like this it hasn't
been discussed but yeah I could see it
yeah okay I hope so
um who knows you know
it all has to do with how well this film
does so I'm just crossing my fingers and
come on go see it yes everybody go see
pray for the devils in theaters now
watch Jacqueline and Christian crush it
so we get more of these great films
thank you both so much for joining me
today I hope to talk to you in the
future
nice to meet you too thanks guys